non non mais c'est très bien
l'histoire attends j'ai un truc dans les
fesses alors non non
mais en fait c'est très grave non mais
c'est pas drôle du tout
concentration en fait elle s'est fait
cambrioler vous comprenez donc ça fait
quand même
250 € de bijoux parce que sinon je vais
pas y arriver d'accord
elle a été portée plainte mais pas sur
le coup donc le problème c'est comme
elle a pas porté plainte sur le coup
c'est mis dans la mouise n'est-ce pas
Bernard et donc
et donc elle est dans la merde
cette histoire il y a eu un cambriolage
le 27d décembre dans la le pavillon
elle n'avait pas vu à ce moment-là que
deux tablettes avaient également été
dérobées donc quand elle porte plainte
elle ne se rend pas compte de sa puis
après elle savise que ces deux tablettes
sur lesquelles il y avait c'est vrai des
vidéos intimes des sextape d'elle voilà
ont été dérobés et le corbeau va
l'appeler un corbeau va l'appeler
quelques semaines après et lui réclame
directement 250000 euros alors on sait
pas
encore je ne sais pas encore puisque
donc elle a porté plainte au
commissariat de Chelles en
Seine-et-Marne et c'est la police
judiciaire de MOOC
la police judiciaire de Meaux est
chargée de l'enquête alors ce qu'on ne
sait pas pour le moment la peau c'était
27 décembre c'est une galère pour rien
c'est une galère totale alors ce qu'elle
a très bien fait ce qui change quand
même par rapport à avant c'est ce qu'un
policier m'a expliqué c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les stars que ce soit
footballeurs artistes quand ils ont un
chantage à la sextape il porte plainte
avant il payait avant il se faisait il
payait elle elle a dit je m'en fous je
ne paye pas et à la portée plainte c'est
ce qu'il faut faire d'ailleurs
effectivement
[Musique]
et en fait moi ce qui m'a fait
halluciner c'est que j'ai lu sur les
réseaux sociaux des gens qui disent
c'est bien fait pour elle elle a qu'à
pas faire de sexter par qu'elle est
connue parce que comme le monde à
l'envers le coupable c'est la personne
qui divule ses vidéos elle a le droit de
faire des vidéos intimes c'est une mère
de famille en plus il faut la respecter
et j'ai l'impression qu'il y a l'ordre
des réseaux c'est devenu la mode et
c'est devenu normal de tout divulguer
des photos des vidéos des conversations
privées ce qui est privé et privé et
j'espère que ce sera très sévèrement
puni parce que c'est elle paye même si
elle paye les vidéos ont été copiées
donc toute façon il faut le punir ça
c'est extrêmement grave elle a eu raison
comme elle est suivie par de nombreuses
jeunes gens elle a raison de montrer en
exemple qu'il faut passer des au
chantage peu importe
ce qu'on a en notre possession une
sextape ou autre chose elle a raison
d'aller directement voir le Commissariat
au commissariat les peines sont lourdes
pourcentage c'est 5 ans de prison et 500
000 euros d'amende et si vous mettez la
menace à exécution ça passe à 7 ans de
prison donc c'est pas un délire anodin
et bénin c'est pour ça que c'est pris
très au sérieux effectivement et que
l'enquête se passe actuellement donc
c'est pour vol avec fraction et chantage
il faut quand même rappeler qu'elle a
plus de 6 milliards de string c'est une
des plus grands stars françaises le
string
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la plus grande star la plus
écoutée dans le bien sûr moi j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour elle et là
c'est grâce à vous que je l'ai connu
j'ai
adoréage parce que certes on lui a volé
de l'argent
aussi je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
maintenant je pense que quand on est
connu il faut faire un peu attention
Guillaume effectivement on est on est
quand même
il a fait des sextape voilà les anonymes
ont le droit de faire les sexes
personnalité que j'ai reçu dans mon
émission qui m'a dit Guillaume on avait
fait une semaine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'expression on embrasse madame
Deluxe
allez merci Jordan merci
Julie de regarder l'émission
merci Jordan d'avoir été la mon chéri